first on CBS mornings a new push to test
the safety of the ever shrinking
airplane seat Airlines have been
downsizing their seats for years that
led Congress to order the FAA in 2018 to
set new standards to ensure passengers
can evacuate a plane in 90 seconds or
less that testing has been widely
criticized for not considering things
like passengers with disabilities today
U.S senator Tammy Duckworth introduces
legislation requiring the FAA to rethink
its review of airline seat size Chris
Van Cleave has followed this story for
years he's at Reagan National Airport
outside Washington Chris good morning
how you doing
well now good morning you may remember
over the summer we told you the FAA was
seeking public comment on the size of
Airline seats the agency received more
than 26
000 in just 90 days more than 200 times
the word torture shows up in those
comments now Senator Duckworth is saying
the FAA essentially needs to do a
do-over
in a simulated cabin that can be filled
with smoke and plunged Into Darkness
the FAA tested the safe size of Airline
seats and how passengers can get out in
90 seconds or less while the volunteer
passengers in the simulated evacuations
had varying seat sizes they did not have
to deal with real life obstacles like
smoke the dark or even luggage and they
were in groups of 60 nowhere near a full
plane load in 2019 the FAA explained
we're going to try to minimize the
variables to the ones that are important
for this particular test airplane seat
width is already down as much as four
inches over the last 30 years to as
little as 16 inches wide and Seed pitch
the distance between rows has shrunk
from about 35 inches to 31 and in some
cases as little as 28 inches allowing
Airlines to add more seats the FAA found
seat size and spacing did not adversely
affect the success of emergency
evacuations but because all participants
were able-bodied adults under 60 then
FAA administrator Steve Dixon
acknowledged the results are useful but
not necessarily definitive Airlines have
added seeds to increase revenue and
impact more people into smaller spaces
and it's going to have an effect when
there's an evacuation Miracle on the
Hudson pilot Captain Sully sullenberger
on our flight it took over three minutes
to evacuate everyone partly because the
airplane was filling up rapidly with
water from back to front but also
because it was real life and we had a
full aircraft six Democratic senators
recently urged the FAA to reconsider its
findings saying not accurately
reflecting the flying public is one of
its most glaring flaws do you think you
could get off an airplane in 90 seconds
not in the normal conditions that I that
I normally travel in today senator Tammy
Duckworth who lost both legs while
serving in Iraq is now proposing
legislation requiring a new FAA seat
size study looking at how real-life
conditions including children seniors
and the disabled as well as the presence
of carry-on bags impacts evacuation
times when you're testing with a not
real world conditions then that gets me
worried airlines are traveling now with
just about every seat filled you can't
just practice evacuating an aircraft
that is only 30 full because that's not
the way commercial Aviation looks today
Captain sullenberger Aviation worker
unions and Veterans groups also all
support this proposed legislation the
FAA says it is continuing to go through
those thousands of public comments but
that it followed guidelines in its
testing that were laid out by Congress
the airlines say safety is their top
priority and they will continue to work
with the FAA Tony
very eye-opening report there Chris the
senator making some good points thank
you very much